[Музика]
привіт усім, мене звати Анна, і я
вчитель англійської мови, я вчителька англійської мови. Я просто вдарив – wahtah
unlatch Ethel and Miss comb-
over home is one with motors but at
the demo Personal prikmetniki think the
fish kill a cent was the
я знаю, що ви
вже досить довго працюєте
в нинішній команді, тому
нам потрібно переглянути деякі речі,
що насправді ми збираємося робити сьогодні.
ніч налаштувати chasse current a
attack popper рівень механічного шуму можна
мити, тож давайте перейдемо до словникового запасу,
і перше, що ми робимо, це їх
особисті прикметники, тому особистісні
прикметники Rick madnikey ключовий уривок
також має дужки давайте поглянемо на
дошку,
і ми '  re збираємося побачити слова
з перекладом після цього ми збираємося
виконати вправу Oh Joe salaz my
Padova мій син a Slava перикулюм охайний
Oh Jaime ледачий lien спосіб тихий хід
обраний дуже терплячий
фіолетовий Арчі дружелюбний Бразилія в гостях
на борту Росії відкриття прийти моторошне коліно
що серйозне серйозне коліно праворуч
ви можете бачити це були його протилежності
антоніми привілей занурений
бюджет: затишний Антонія мама лікар
повільний Варма ви тримаєте тут про інструмент як
ворог виїмку  in yo ass LaVon залишити
наш співведучий, тому ці слова є
балакучі нетерплячий недружній
веселий нервовий неохайний і працьовитий,
тож тепер давайте перейдемо до вправи, щоб наша
вправа підказувала нам, що ми повинні
зіставити слова прикметники з їхніми
протилежностями, щоб  Ви можете бачити, що
протилежності є змішаними або junto
nemo unus, які я знаю, але eh aqui para
mix of animal very mission in ashes
address vamos a dacha
Boyet не прагматичний ніггер на прізвисько
antonia moment, тому давайте поглянемо
на перше слово the  перше слово охайна
жива емоційна покупка lova buy
словацька акуратна
Чая чіп chesty oh honey, яке
слово праворуч може бути протилежним
слову охайний
давайте подивимось  d давайте подумаємо, хм
, це точно не балакучий, це,
мабуть, щось у тому, щоб говорити правильно,
нетерпляче, очевидно, є інше
слово, яке підійде до цього, і давайте
ще раз подивимося на всі ці слова,
у другому стовпці є передостаннє слово,
яке насправді є  наш
Антоній так, що це слово неохайний так охайно
збігається з неохайний, так що вони
протилежні або дуже це зараз Hynek охайний
неохайний давайте перейдемо до наступного ледачий
ледачий означає, що ти віддаляєшся, так що
людина, яка не приречена, не любить
багато робити  правильна діяльність, то що
було б слово протилежне, так що
людина, яка є певною мірою активна і робить
багато речей, то давайте подумаємо, що робота
це слово працьовита настільки працьовита
означає використовувати це слово, щоб говорити
про людину, яка любить  наполегливо працює або
просто наполегливо працює або просто люблю
працьовитого учасника karrasco vomica шлях
вгору ми говоримо мелодію no yucca baccata pret
suya наступне слово тихо тихо, як ви
можете бачити на малюнку, означає людину
th  at не любить занадто багато говорити, що
д-р.  Лавінія відірватись, просто не в
тарілці, трішки над нею не так неохайно
ах президент я б бачив це добре, ти перехрестився
добре так, мамо Антонія, давайте подивимося
на стовпець і праворуч, і
перше слово насправді те, що  нам
потрібно так, що це слово балакучий правильно,
і давайте перейдемо до наступного слова
.  seldin
У мене є Chikatilo donna de plata,
зараз весела мадам
збирається в Лондон НАТО, але Chester
peatonal ubukata у
нас є префікс, який ми додаємо до слова
пацієнт доза пацієнта Мохаммед Атта
префікс dr.  Neville escucha stinking doc
буквально Мустафа папуга Слава навіть у
середині води мій вірш акровірш так
що це, безперечно, хвилюється
нетерплячий що щодо наступного слова
friendly drew illumining так
що це слово знову використовується як протилежність
з префіксом, тому нам знадобиться  лише дві
літери, які потрібно додати на
початку слова, тепер думка про те, що якщо у вас
є книга викрадача chato slovis
Joe Bereta
Antonia найбільш дружній до лави, давайте
подивимося на стовпець праворуч, і так,
ви вже зрозуміли це правильно  слово,
яке ми підібрали, є непривітним. О
доктор дружній y Антонія недружній
Єрусалим природне відкриття наступне
слово, до якого ми повинні знайти антонім,
це слово calm spooky knee, тому,
коли ми повинні зіставити його з Anthony,
ми будемо використовувати  слово, яке буде
описувати людину, було трохи хитким і
занепокоєним, і це слово, безумовно,
буде словом «нервовий», тому наступне й
останнє занепокоєне, що ми повинні відповідати
його  навпроти стоїть слово серйозне місто
, назва якого Ямагучі Москва др.  Шелдон
і може вчорашній новий luden на рік
намалювали кратер Шалхуба но wit Lubitz
bhagavati self Rossella
що було б слово веселий, яке ми
підберемо до цього прикметника, тож давайте
подивимося на остаточну картинку, ось
як усі ці прикметники збігаються зі
своїми протилежностями з  їхні антоніми
ojou-sama розмовляють модем попереду ні, але
бачив Бретт божевілля
Антонія момент сповільненого ходу приніс
останню позицію Enya, тож ось тут
прикметники особистості Я сподіваюся, що
вам було корисно переглянути цю тему,
щоб вони могли  split my ethnic americium
of a Cristo Amandla opus також благослови, що цей
рік був дуже дорогим я повинен сказати
блог Lavas харизма Британський король після
Італії немає pareja de mando
романтичний мусульманський Месія динамо не було
HSN він збирається рухатися ти ще мертвий
на одну ніч номінантом сатирика в але
найкрасномовнішому гнобителі є безкоштовний
кардамон, тож давайте продовжимо загальний
огляд часів хто є Хайнлайном
подивіться тут, на малюнку, у нас є три
аспекти мій матеріальний аспект це простий
безперервний ідеальний шум, який я не
досягає парафіяльного коліна людина завжди
робив моє добре ім'я, тому давайте ближче
подивимося на всі ці часи життєвий буй,
але вони майже були  нічні зміни кожного
есе, тому давайте почнемо з верхнього лівого
кута, який namitha live aho bikini
Hokuto Chicano Union ami bacha mo
past simple past simple Manoli
престижне шоу ma Djibouti squad Nisha
abou престижне пізнання hoodoo zaba
hata Суматра з престижним up has
simple if I  я повинен представити простий там
іди додому і діловий партнер сам так
швидко простий описує дію вже
закінчено лікар мама могла б
уперти на минулому простому бідності Latasha
пробачте вам ваше покриття, як
віртуалізований перемикач і чи
водяний знак тільки вершини ідіот відповідає не
відплатить Jorah Manoa atresia
середня школа та гуртожиток, вони сказали, що Раґхав
Томо це все про минуле просте, тому
тут ви можете побачити приклад  le Я їздив до
Німеччини минулого року так, так, Dhoni my
China Маноло Хіроко просто як версія
ідея розмовляє з китайським
стилістом Маноло Хіроко Тодд навіть
не обертається не лосось ніяк, тільки тому, що
версія добре запитує клієнти,
давайте перейдемо до минулого
безперервно  минуле continious все також
у минулому, це очевидно, але те, що є
особливого в минулому, продовжує
колосально закривати її минуле continious
Trivedi's new Yoho з past Simple з
prosto her Manolo Hutchison але nah mah
stoah певно продовжує продюсер
зникає капризний випадок парафія
про мене  моя ботаніка Муса розігріває Реджі
Яаков радник над ним Боб Аліса про
Буддакан бхарата раджа партнер по дому
ха Честер лікар каже, що я не знаю
вище конкретного моменту
о ні про назву парафії над
перешкодою на моїй нижній частині ой так використовується минуле
безперервне  розповісти про
незавершені дії в минулому лікарі
та масивні Арчани дають Маноло г-дай
перш за все, за винятком на кратані момент не
виключає всіх w  як читання who see
chital подібний процес it's a tonya
Oranje тривалий час використовується для розмови
про тривалість
pradosham ідея і останній
з минулих часів тут це минулий досконалий час
Manoli da Cunha Nietzsche каже, що
я вокаліст номінально da  Кунья
Ніцше Наташа бідність про
гео так мідь і Авіла в сінджі,
коли весь океан міндомо савани
Пачеко віртуалізований
об'єкт веде соло полірує інша
завершена дія минулого, що
відбулася до іншої минулої дії або
інших минулих дій, тож давайте подивимося
на приклад  після того, як вона закінчила
домашнє завдання, вона вийшла зі своїм другом або
Джекілом Котеджі, хто знає короля
Шейлу Роберта Адама як новини про Даніеля,
коли я ловлю удачу hula Telus women résumé,
і це те, що кожен учень повинен робити
правильно, тому давайте перейдемо до сьогодення
, це щось  це відбувається зараз, і ми
почнемо з теперішнього простого О
джипери Хода Макдонаф Патна
Мікаса теперішній простий парафія новий
перст  igious псевдонім Stowe Vermont,
мабуть, престижно, представлений простий
Latasha cover у пропорції, яку ви тримаєте,
це мобілізує,
тому ми поговоримо про наші звички, використовуючи
цей час, тож давайте подивимося на
використання, яке також виражає загальну істину, тому
звички та загальна істина представляють просту
купу  Присутні зразки сепаратинового
попелу, які отримують tyke це мед факт,
що вона закликала Правда турецька
Михайлович Арісто на теперішній прості
дані показують бідність Pro графіки виконано
розклади dr.  Росс присідає, і давайте
подивимося на приклад, тут я студент,
так, мичання про так, студент, який
був китайським великим пальцем, загальна правда, що
блокує довіру до Logica, відкриває
їм, тому він каже, що я студент, наступні
повороти тут у теперішньому  теперішній
безперервний гностик на ім'я Джон Маккей
Месзарос vimarsanam о так, теперішній
безперервний коротший, наприклад, у
виробництві та також Ліма ша
безперервно, що тривалість це
виробництво, коли його дорогий електронний лист
низ проклятого OHHS Латаша Махабхарата прагья
дає бхаву в даний момент
Прія Месзарос  скажи мить гарна мить
над Індією бомба турецький вокаліст Maha Maha
в Лос-Анджелесі
симча так Валачі, що Шіва передає
повідомлення, що я був так скривджений Ніа Брітанець
з Дробо біда в дії зв'язок
абрикосовий сімейний період прірва рух передзвін
о, ні бум / OS  пообіцяйте Aras переміщення
Chama some Soho Terra Nova mobile
анаграму зробленого моменту, так що
це теперішнє безперервне давайте подивимося
на його використання англійською  дія відбувається
і час розмови тимчасова
акція і тут ми маємо два приклади для
обох вживань мій мафіозний
насамперед дуже по телевізору Ваня вони
читають книжки зараз коли обіцяють
пенсіонер Канішка я в синіх джинсах
сьогодні
так evadne no show Симеон так, так
Ваня jaffna живе в Ajinca перемикач
і абрикос Ходжінс і початковий ELISA
роговий так дуже chavvy Jota Jota Donna роздаймо
модем проклятого Отіса я теперішній
безперервний і останній теперішній час
тут давайте подивимось  that's present
perfect austin muchacha que muchos
l'anima назви парафії, яку я бачу
там, present perfect чому ми використовуємо його
коли ми використовуємо його ми використовуємо його, щоб говорити
про дію, давайте повернемо це в
минуле і триває дотепер  або
має результат у теперішньому часі, тому він
має результат прямо зараз того, що ми
вже досягли. Oranje present
perfect, тому що Thomas adaptive shabiha
verita Pro Geo
Jakob pachala sub-menu amo in aboard OSE
дивовижне злиття лука практично
в Майамі призвело до CAG не зафіксувати
вдячність Yahoo Канішку. Я вже
читав цю книгу, або він працював у
ІТ-страхі протягом п'яти років, запис mcurtin
sanam curve у прогресивній сфері IT
JPI troll comparative of omen  Olomouc
навіть поділяється Adagio preservant, тому ми
маємо результат, який він працював протягом
певного часу, і він продовжує працювати
в цій сфері, тому це те, де
теперішній час тепер ми закінчили з ними
більшість наших плечей це про
парафіяльну природу сказати  теперішнє просте теперішнє
безперервне теперішнє ідеальне Ібрагім
Мондо Остін Йохо толкатися сер, моєму черевику
потрібне шасі не застрягло в моєму матеріальному
аспекті, простий безперервний
матеріал ідеальний, тож давайте подивимося
та майбутній зразок запису
Ханумана, тепер моя бутанська вагіна
вибрала  чоловік, який носив його брат дія, що
відбудеться в майбутньому dr.  Джіа так,
я розміщу це в своїй книзі ні-мо, немає плакатів, зараз
я шочет станиця ні-а-а-а, я
буду їсти мексиканську їжу
завтра після ya-yee шлунка секунд
Хорватія ммм тако, це звучить дуже
смачно, так що це щось
станеться в майбутньому  завтра, можливо, наступного
тижня, можливо, наступного року,
хто знає, можливо, я поїду до Мексики наступного
року, і я буду їсти тако прямо там,
показує, що нудота зробила сама собою моя здобич
дія була Наама аборт дев'ять
відеокамер у русі над Каллісто
майбутній простий, так що наступний час що  ми
зосереджуємось на майбутній
безперервній гностичній природі Cigna comenzar
Wisconsin через месію прийшов Осіріс
Руслана matzah майбутнє безперервне виробництво мого ботинка,
коли вони вибирали свої
кадри, безперервне знання масштабування камери,
я повинен сказати, будда виробництва
SF приніс вам додому партнера, який є таким
tac-x майбутнє виробництво Будди, що є
моєю здобиччю серед технічних ідей, але Девід
Бахаті, сер
сімейний момент, о, моя здобич, дія
буде відбуватися  t деякий час у
майбутньому приклад буде саме тут, у цей час,
завтра я буду читати
африканський кретин
сейшів Будди Роберти шері yatra Buddha chitato це документ про ідею виробництва,
коли обитель Маноло мо була
піхвою
майбутній безперервний час, який
допоможе  ми робимо речення звучати правильно
і останнє тут це
ідеальне майбутнє Астана Джессіка Месарос vamonos
l'anima це ідеальне майбутнє моя
бутоньєрка да Конноллі
пророча природа ножиці, які мають
проклятий над своїм латоша бідність нащадковий
ключ Вірджинія один є доброчесною людиною
на якому я бачу, що один одного не зробили в
той момент, коли у нього з'явилася версія, людина на борту
відкрита aha момент моєї
ідеї Ньюмана Будда Арджуни має негайно
рухатися частинками з
Махабхаратою Шиваджі просто досконалим майбутнім,
тому давайте подивимося на
значення дії, яке буде завершено
перед іншою подією, яка відбудеться
в майбутньому, тому gia Yakubu робить версію,
яку
touhou fucks done, це приємно  una Gia oh my
booty
давайте подивимося на приклад до того
часу, коли ми закінчимо домашнє завдання мама
приготує вечерю
О, Джуд, Тохо момент, щоб визнати
версію каньйону дамаш новий робот
мама
абрикос віу Неш орбіта, так що це
ідеальне майбутнє ми  використовуйте його, щоб говорити про
дії, які
ми завершимо в майбутньому до того
часу, коли відбудеться інша дія в Монтані,
штат Вірджинія в Шоджі, тому я сподіваюся,
що це досить зрозуміло, тому тепер
давайте попрактикуємося як iris ma practicum, о,
ви вже бачили  David Chiu break you must
join up / Ellen, то давайте почнемо
практикувати наше завдання — заповнити
пропуски правильними формами дієслів
, які дано нам у дужках
Неш Варма кумири Дані стриманий
недискретний епістатичний Слава ти, мабуть,
знаєш формули, але я  Ой, добре, проведу
час, Маркус, Меркьюрі, дитинство, тому
Майкл Де Пальма Хонам відновив це
показує шанс, мадам, я з Шибата О
Джо, але тепер часткова Емма Регіна я
вчора спізнився до школи,
хм, це в попередньому  послано в минулому
або в майбутньому, а слово вчора
показує нам, що це щось у
минулому вчора щось сталося правильно,
тому ми скажемо, що це речення має
бути в минулому зразку, мабуть, не хочеться, щоб
ми могли esto como пройти просто
через магазин тако  at the predict a pasta with
bellissimo він ганяється за начо call a
конкретне not sie da vid bolus або Jeff
Dunham з Padma bottom of Shibata
минулого простої форми дієслова to be
doctor was I was late to school
yesterday the next one I’m chocolate
right
Ну що ж, фраза прямо зараз показує нам, що
щось відбувається в момент, коли ми
говоримо правильно О JPL Meszaros так, він
Шоколад
лідерство шотландський вибір відео через
справжній Meszaros Денні момент моє
дно кристала на теперішній безперервний
верхній верх Dunham з попкорну Маша  Маша
я зараз їм шоколад номер
третій мій друг їздив до Франції цієї
осені. Цієї осені ще не прийшов.
cie була в Китаї
Bella dr.  Сем мій чобот
Мама Ніцше Skidata шоу показує з буде, сер на мою
попою Немо, давайте запропонуємо мою попку
хористу простати мій попой
майбутній зразок Ніцше, тож ми повинні
сказати, що мій друг поїде до
друзів за цим номером товару на цей час
наступного тижня
Кейт відвідає  вебінар для тих, хто
вивчає мистецтво навчити моє завзято відео до
вебінару детектив Чая повинен додати сильного
джам'я ван Я сподіваюся, що список може бути таким, що в
моїй книзі Nemo me mask incretin двоюрідного брата
Akiyama van буддійська кнопка зі стрілкою це
Shinagawa пульт про факел новий момент
о мій  Boot Nemo наші футболки та мої
ніші для взуття моє резюме було заморожено
наступного тижня двоюрідний брат Меркурі Капур з
моєї ботаніки тільки я моє майбутнє Maserati
безперервно, тому ми скажемо, що цього разу
наступного тижня
Кейт відвідає вебінар, тому цей вебінар
буде постійним  номер 5
Я пройшов 707 тисяч кроків до обіду
dou V dou так вибір Роб Лоу
так подорож випадкова неприємність, тож тут ми
повинні з'ясувати, що саме станеться
так до
обіду і  yway показує нам, що це має бути
ідеальним аспектом dr.  slovis pallucci Nia
за номером обіду, тому що я повинен сказати, що
моя попка ідеальна ніша як EXO muscaria
не повинна бути бісером Нечаєв jefra показувати
просто такий крокет
mohammad javad a past perfect я
пройшов 7000 кроків до обіду
номер 6 John B до 10 країн Джон
Бул  Odessa Tech Regina Mooka Morimoto
Yahoo doe Smith переміщення тварин Збереження
в G Аллах мій мопед коліно коліно
призвело до Джеффа Данема з частки
ma'am I'm of a Cristo, звичайно, ідеальний,
тому ми скажемо, що Джон
був у 10  країни наступне речення
ми тільки закінчимо її домашнє завдання до того часу, коли
її батьки повернуться додому
Раджу кулі, але Лілі Прудомме Ваная
поклоняється масовим потребам дуньї, так
що це, звичайно, буде в майбутньому, і
це буде
завершена дія, яка колись закінчиться  у майбутньому
або Джефф Данхем із Padma Buddha Maj
про майбутню ідеальну
Лілі закінчить свою домашню роботу до
того часу, коли її батьки повернуться додому
номер 8 Кріс прочитав книгу, коли щось почув,
коли  він чув щось круте
навіть вибір Патруль сказав так тренер Девід
Моралес О Маноло багато я бачу
некуплений відпочинок на Одіна Араса тому в
прямому ефірі в чаті доктора Канішки.  Сусман,
якого я бачу, Кріс повстанець доса Доха, що
так, хто я, Шабат минуле
безперервне, звичайно, тому ми скажемо, що
Кріс читав книгу, коли він почув
щось dr.  Ян заткнувся Канішка, хто
Тоні момент вибір Халіфа Чифс
і останнє речення тут Сем, як дивитися
голлівудські блокбастери, це те, що його звичка
або це те, що він робив у
минулому або що він буде робити в майбутньому,
а тут ми можемо припустити, що ми
розмова про звичку цієї
людини динамо горілка махапрабху спокуса
Мухаррам Опра відьма Косіма мода
рухатися таким чином форма Adobe Itza
вага голлівудський гірськолижний блокбастер Dona
moça Падуя Кремона Варапрасад Капрона
вона колонія фото banya memoriam про
хор, який думав у голові  a проклятий
над сучасним простим, тому ми скажемо,
що Сем любить дивитися голлівудські
блокбастери Audra, які лосось miss
komova Morrissey без бюстгальтера
ось воно з тензором основними,
які ми зазвичай використовуємо в англійській
мові
, це майже сер Джастіна - доктор.  Гарра,
це було добре на тебе